is this just possible it's impossible
here magnus there actually being a bit
flashy
uh showing off there with his last move
he's actually going offering to give a
pawn back
if black captures the rook but that king
of pawn lane game is winning for white
the white king will outflank
out maneuver the black king so yeah now
white's king's just gonna step forward
towards the black pawn and he's not
letting this one slip
magnus let it slip earlier when it was
sharp when the queen's on the board but
no end game mistakes
from him of course and he will be the
winner of the first semi-final match
with a win
in this game and it's about to be three
extra pawns for white black's remaining
pawn dropping and ronin resigns
erroneous eventually resigned so it was
close though but magnus carlsen is the
winner of the fourth
and final game and he's also the winner
of the first
semi-final match against levon aronian
it was a slow game magnus had the
advantage for a long time
suddenly losing it maybe he's looking at
it right now we can see a big
reaction on his face